ich muss ein losziehen du kannst mehrere
Lose ziehen jetzt pass auf pass auf du
solltest wissen was das für lose sind
das rote sind unverschämte Fragen und
das Grüne sind harmlose Fragen Ben das
ganze fragenlotte du kannst so lang
ziehen wie du willst du
kannst so einfach da legen wir die jetzt
mal raus du kannst sie auch alle ziehen
ähm und dann fangen wir an du musst sie
auch nicht alle beantworten wir gehen
wir fangen mit einer unverschämten an
und dann wenn falls Sie schlimm ist
nehmen wir gleich
ich muss die ja nicht vorlesen ne mus
ich les die nur dann kann man meine
Mimik anschauen dass ich ja euch total
kacke finde oder eben auch
nicht ja das ist ja geht ja total
schnell sie haben als Musiker angefangen
und sind dann aber Kabarettist geworden
waren sie als Musiker zu unbegabt das
ist nicht unverschämt das ist wahr
ehrlich sicher ich war einfach nicht gut
genug und
bin dann aber in ein Genre gewechselt wo
man immer wieder Musik machen kann und
habe jetzt 20 Jahre lang immer auch
Musik gemacht und langsam wird's besser
und deswegen kann ich jetzt nämlich
Songs machen ohne mich gleich lächerlich
zu machen m aber es stimmt ich habe als
Musiker angefangen und die Ansagen waren
besser als die Songs und deswegen wurde
es Kabarett mit immer weniger Songs
jetzt werden es immer mehr weil jetzt
bin ich nämlich ein halbwegs akzeptabler
rocken Roller und dem fröhne ich super
war gar nicht schlimm gut aber das ist
denn Musik hat die höhere Kunst dann
es ist eine tolle Kunst aber am Anfang
war es wirklich so so gerade in
Schulzeiten da wollte man in der Band
spielen und das hat sich aber relativ
schnell rauskristallisiert dass das
nicht reicht aber ich mache nach wie vor
wahnsinnig gern Musik und zeig es auch
auf der Bühne also ich spiel Gitarre und
Akkordeon und sing Lieder aber für eine
Musikkarriere würde es wirklich nicht
reichen und das muss man irgendwann mal
mal wissen und wenn da steht unbegabt
dann steht da halt unbegabt aber ich übe
weil ich Musik toll find so und
verschämthit auf der Bühne Rauchen reden
und singen sie fühlen Sie sich zu Hause
auf der Bühne na sicher ich ma noch ganz
andere Sachen auf der Bühne ja was den
ich habe mich schon mal ausgezogen nein
z.B waren tolle Erfahrung nur einmal
aber blank gezogen wie sich das gehört
schön nee auf der Bühne fühle ich mich
wirklich zu Hause ja aber ich fühle mich
auch zu Hause zu Hause und es ist ein
anderes zu Hause eine andere Art von zu
Hause aber ja ich fühle mich da sehr
heimisch und und zu Hause was ist das
Publikum Partner ein Gesprächspartner
was ist das was hat das für eine Rolle
wenn man auf der Büne steht klassische
publikumsrolle also die haben sich dafür
entschieden ja mich zu sehen und meine
Kunst und haben dafür sogar gezahlt und
das habe ich ja vorher schon gesagt das
finde ich so großartig und so so ein
ehrenbezeugnis dass ich da sehr gerne
was dafür tu dass die wiederkommen dass
die da bleiben dass die glücklich sind
dass die einen guten Abend haben dass
sie nach Hause gehen sagen wow ich bin
was mit nichts vergleichbar mit nichts
vergleichb doch es gibt natürlich auch
sehr viele andere schöne Dinge gut essen
Sex würde ich jetzt nicht auf der Bühne
machen das meine ich mit dem anderen zu
Hause was auch überall sein kann auch im
Wald sie haben verschiedene
Bühnenprogramme und schreiben dazu noch
Bücher woher kommen alle ihre
Ideen haben auch schon gehabt ich bin
ich guck und mach und und arbeite es
sind auch nicht es gibt Leute die machen
viel viel mehr also ich habe manchmal
komme ich auf Geschichten die also ich
verwerf noch viel viel mehr Ideen als
ich eigentlich ma es ist ganz ganz
normal es gibt einfach immer wieder
Dinge die es wert sind erzählt zu werden
und ich glaube da muss man sich immer
wieder zurückbiamen nur dann hat
wirklich Substanz so eine Geschichte die
noch nicht erzählt worden ist oder so
noch nicht es gibt's immer wieder und
wenn das mal nicht mehr ist dann ist
sowieso Feierabend also das ist immer so
die Frage wo nehmen Sie alle Ihre Ideen
her ja so so sind diese Fragen das sind
sie machen das so toll die Leute haben
wahnsinnig viele Ideen jeder hat es
immer wieder Gedanken und und ich glaube
die diese wirklich künstlerische Arbeit
ist es diese Ideen in Worte zu fassen in
Bilder zu prägen in ein Foto hinein zu
pressen in ein in eine Komposition zu
tränken das ist ja das was uns ausmacht
die Ideen die Menschen sind voll von
Kreativität und Wahnsinn und albernhit
und Abgründen D würde ich dir
wiedersprechen und 95% des Fernsehens
sind schrott aber auch weil auch weil
die Programmmacher so feige sind und und
und das Publikum würde viel mehr
vertragen und das weiß man doch es gibt
so viele tolle Arten dann probiert
wieder jemand und hat keine Quoten dann
muss man die halt mal erziehen ich meine
es gibt ja wir haben ein Staatsfernsehen
da wieder gezahlt da könnte man doch
mutiger sein sage ich immer und es gibt
ja die Beispiele sogar bei uns von
gelungenen Serien von tollen Sachen da
sollen sich die Fernsehen machen
am Riemen reißen und das Fernsehpublikum
offener sein es geht es gibt immer das
BBC Beispiel und es es gibt's es geht
aber du bist jemand der das die das
Publikum erzieht würdest du sagen du
mutest den was zu natürlich das sind
aber letztlich auch die meisten
Bühnenkünstler ich es ist so schön es
ist wie ein Lob aber da bin ich bin ich
einzigartig aber diesen diesen es ist ja
nicht in dem Sinne eine dogmatische
Erziehung sondern man sagt ich ich ich
ich leg da viel Herzblut rein und gebe
mir da sehr viel Mühe und habe auch eine
Hochachtung vor denen und weiß auch was
die wollen aber trotzdem muss es ja also
ich ich ich liefer da mein bestes ab und
dann kann ich nur noch beten dass es
denen gefällt ja da sind wir wieder beim
Thema Angst bin ich gut genug ja sicher
oh ja das kennen wir alle das ist
äh es wächst stetig und es ist doch ein
guter Weg und
wenn es runtergeht dann dann muss man
noch besser sein oder was anders machen
und das ist ständig im Wandel
natürlich ist man von Selbstzweifeln
zerfressen und das ist auch für mich
nicht ganz schlecht wenn ich mir zu
sicher wäre dann oder die Haltung hätte
die sind alle blöd und ich bin super und
wenn die es nicht kapieren dann kann ich
auch nicht ändern ja dann würde ich
könnte ich meine Miete nicht bezahlen
also so einfach ist das eine
unverschämte
frage sie haben auch ein Fotobuch
veröffentlicht können sie von ihren
Texten nicht
leben
ja mit dem Foto füt man leichtter an der
Seite wenn man es mal gemacht hat hast
du eine Ahnung hast du eine Ahnung ich
habe an keinem Buch so lange gearbeitet
wie an diesem scheiß Fotobuch es war
viel anstrengender viel teurer viel Zeit
inensiver so ein Text schreibt sich dann
schon auch mal runter dann ist die Seite
voll und so ein Foto da habe ich drei
Filme verknipst weil ich alles analog
mache und auch kein Photoshop und nix
das ist natürlich ein Handicap no no
Keyboards no
Photoshop no Overdubs es war eine
wahnsinnige Arbeit den Verlag davon zu
überzeugen ich bin nicht reich geworden
mit diesem Fotobuch hätte ich mal Texte
gemacht aber ich bin total stolz drauf
und ich konnte vorher von den Texten
Leben ich kann jetzt von den Texten
leben aber jetzt habe ich auch noch
Fotos m finde ich jetzt gar nicht so
unverschämt m das war eher ein wirklich
ein langgehegter Wunsch und
bin bis heute den Leuten im Verlag zu
Dank verpflichtet dass wir es
durchgeboxt also mit denen ich
durchgeboxt habe und mir zu Dank
verpflichtet dass ich da so hartnäckig
war weil sich es doch sehr gut verkauft
hat aber ich habe natürlich das ist viel
teurer in der Produktion und ich wollte
dass es relativ günstig ist ich hät bei
dem fotoverlag machen können für 50 €
oder eben im Taschenbuch und sehr gut
dass es Faden geheftet das ist eine
spitzendruckerei und es kosten Zehner
das geht auch nur wenn der Herr Künstler
kein vch nimmt und eine sehr geringe
Rage Range von dem was er verdient aber
wir wollten das alle machen haben wir an
einem Strand gezogen und ich bin so
glücklich mit dem und zum Glück kaufen
es genug dass es tatsächlich ein
plusgeschäft ist und ich werde immer
wieder mit Fotos arbeiten aber auch mit
Texten und dann werde ich hoffen dass
ich von beiden leben kann unverschämte
Frage Weg in deinem aktuellen Programm
gibt's da auch wieder eine dihow immer
es gibt immer immer di ist auch immer
das was am meisten Arbeit mach also die
Dias entwickeln und die Reihenfolge und
das sind dann immer erstmal 100 dann
dann sind 200 dann mache ich diese
schriftdias nein ich ma sie nicht im
Computer ich mache mit Schreibmaschine
das wird abfotografiert es ist
eine schöne Arbeit anstrengende teure
Arbeit aber es ist einfach auch wert und
di sch das ist so schön oldschol der
Frosch ihr Alter Ego vertritt eine
Einstellung die sie nicht
haben wie schaffen Sie es ihn so
überzeugend darzustellen na weil die
Einstellung in mir natürlich auch drin
ist
ähm
viel Arbeit und viel gesichtsgymnastik
also allem viel
stassbergübungen also wenn man diesen
Frosch der der der der der vermeintlich
grinst ja auch immer also der hat immer
dieses diese
ganz dies ist ganz lustige ist
Sch grünen Licht und der dann
diese lange Zunge und dann muss man das
Üben und dann ist schon wenn die
Physiognomie stimmt und dann auch dieses
dieses dieses permanente das ist nicht
mehr staunen das ist
so der kann nur so grinsen und der
verachtet aber die Welt musiert sich
über alles ja aber der ist auch sehr
resignativ trotzdem er dieses Maul hat
dies mein Cousin mein Cousin ist
überfahren worden von einem
Fahrradfahrer
saublöd das erste Mal treffen ich habe
noch zwei Fragen die werde ich
abarbeiten Herr Kameramann der
Kameramann hat ein Piercing durch die
Augenbraue das tut doch weh nur am
Anfang sie sind kameratist Autor und
liefern diversen Magazinen und
zeitnungen Textbeiträge müssen sie ihre
Texte mehrfach verwerten um überhaupt
davon leben zu können
unv wahr und einleuchtend und auch gut
also ich bin ein großer Freund von
zweitverwertungen weil man nämlich
doppelt Geld kriegt nein also also auch
künstlerisch also wenn manchmal ist es
ja ein Magazin will was eine Kolumne
oder sowas dann hast du a Druck dann
schreibst du das Ding und vielleicht ist
es ja gut und dann wenn du es dann für
ein Buch übernimmst oder für die Bühne
arbeitet man daran sieht vielleicht dass
es ein ja es war eben doch nur eine
Zeitungskolumne und weg damit oder aber
es es wirklich eine Idee die Substanz
hat und die anders viel besser gewesen
wäre und dann sagt man na für die Glosse
so gerade vielleicht noch aber hey der
Redakteur hat gesagt ganz gut und der
Chef vom Dienst hat gepennt und sie
haben es halt gedruckt und mir dieses
wahrlich schäbige ze Zeilenhonorar
überwiesen aber man hat eine tolle Idee
und dieser eine Satz geht dann in die
Zweitverwertung das ist nichts schlimmes
also auch eine Arbeitsmethode work
Arbeit Arbeitsmethode und es ist ja auch
sagen wir mal ich hätte jetzt eine
Kolumne und nachher mache ich ein Buch
mit den Kolumnen da freuen sich die
Leser ja auch weil sie kennen sie aus
der Zeitung und wollen das Buch da ist
niemand dabei sagt es zweitwer hab wir
alle schon in der Zeitung ja dann müssen
sie das Buch nicht kaufen aber im
Gegenteil man will es oft und manchmal
entdeckt man eben auch dadurch also hast
jetzt wirklich schon dreimal und der
wird dadurch nicht besser schmeißen noch
endlich mal weg und erst bei der zweit
dritt oder neun Verwertung checkt man
das dass es eigentlich na ja zumindest
es war Geld aber für die Ewigkeit ist es
nicht also es ist ein gutes gutes
Korrektiv sogar ich habe noch eine
schöne Frage und Wehe sie ist nicht
schön weil es ist die Schlussfrage wir
müssen einen extrem entspannten Schluss
kriegen sie haben Germanistik Politik
Wissenschaft und Philosophie studiert
ist all dieses Wissen notwendig um so
ein abwechslungsreicher Kabarettist zu
sein ist
nett weiß ich nicht ich habe so
wahnsinnig gern studiert
und für mich war es wichtig also ich
habe richtig was gelernt und find das
ein fand großartig also ich finde auch
diese ganzen unireformen furchtbar weil
für mich war diese Art zu studieren
super weil ich so viel Disziplin und im
Kopf habe von Haus aus dass ich dass ich
hätte da nie so Larifari und dann bin
ich noch 10 Jahre eingeschrieben also
ich war das nie sondern ich fand das
eher wirklich eine Chance und ganz toll
aber ich hatte auch sehr gute
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer und Profs und so
ich habe da richtig was mitgenommen ob
es notwendig ist weiß ich nicht für mich
war es es ja ich bedanke mich für das
Gespräch war sehr ja sehr schön ist
alles im Internet ist halt das Medium
der Zukunft aber ist noch Papier tschüss
vielen Dank ich habe zu danken super wow
schön das war doch mal ein nettes
Interview das freut mich